because the energy and supply crisis has
once again demonstrated how easy it is
for our lives to be disrupted by hitches
in the supply chain so is consumer
behavior part of the solution and would
living more sustainably help resolve
those big international supply and chain
issues
jen to you first of all so we are
experiencing various supply issues so is
there a green root out of this and is
there a way that consumers can help
themselves
i think consumers are going to have to
get used to this
global supply chains are only as strong
as the weakest link they're a chain like
anything else
and climate change is going to lead to
extreme weather events droughts and
other shortages
so it might not be that we can green our
way out of this or that consumers will
just learn to do better it's that we're
going to have to learn to be more
resilient and we're going to have to
learn to deal with shortages popping up
do you agree mike that we've just got to
get our heads around it or is there
something that we can do i mean everyone
talks about shopping locally i know
there's one interesting statistic local
deliveries emit less than half as much
co2 per item than online only retailers
so can we take actions that will help
ourselves
well it's a bit of both and there's
definitely things that we can do
uh as individuals and as a society to
alleviate some of the problems that
jen's talking about so for example you
know the less energy we need to consume
the less we're going to be reliant um on
energy sources some of which might come
from other countries you know the more
of our own food
we can produce ourselves the less will
be interrupted by by supply chain uh
problems and you know the less we get
through
uh you know tons of material goods um
we you know we take some of the pressure
off the system and but there's no doubt
that you know we need to change the way
we live quite a bit most of the time we
can do that in a way which if we're
smart about it we can actually use it as
an opportunity to improve the quality of
our lives not it's not like a wearing a
hair shirt but we do need to be
when we change habits a bit yeah jen
i'll just a quick thought on that it's
got to be in people's interests hasn't
it because globalization is out there
there's no putting that back in the tin
is is there do people need to be
motivated in some way to do the right
thing
i think people need to be motivated but
i think we also have to realize that
everything mike was just talking about
is a systemic change
it's dealing with how we grow our food
how we move goods around the world how
we produce how we consume and that goes
beyond what an individual can do in
their own personal lives it doesn't mean
we're powerless and there's always
things that we can do okay it does mean
that we still have to keep thinking
about how we can systematically tackle
the climate crisis okay in a way that
will be green and productive